et bien bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale
tv l'actualité retard sur l'heure du jeu
d'échecs
et bien si la 10e partie de ce
championnat du monde ni fier 2006 entre
la lumière kramnik et de céline topaloff
nous allons voir la 10e partie de ce
match avec le grand maître international
jean-luc chavanon déjà présents pour la
neuvième voilà où bonjour stéphane roof
donc oui ben une dizaine partie donc qui
s'y tient toutes ses promesses puisque
on est en famille qu au tournant on va
dire oui
il vient de perdre la 9e il vient de
concéder davantage pour la première fois
du match puisqu'il est mené 5-4 au début
de cette partie mais surtout il reste
trois parties il reste trois parties
donc il faut qu'il remonte déjà au score
il faut qu'ils oublient toutes ces
histoires de toilette et qui font parler
matin dans un petit peu de folklore des
listes à anvers mais donc et puis il
faut qu'il se concentre sur sur cette
revanche puisque la topalov vient quand
même de lui donner un bon coup au moral
puisque avec deux victoires pendant la
défense slave une avec les noirs et vue
de nez avec les blancs topalov quand
même là un petit peu provoqué en lui
montrant que finalement c'est peut-être
plus le nouveau spécialiste de la slave
oui peut-être peut-être en tout cas
victoires et 5 4 on peut dire que cette
histoire quand même de toilette a
profité 100% topalov 100% il a il a
réussi son coup il sait bien rafraîchi
les idées il avait il été complètement
ko en début de match on avait
l'impression que qu'il allait perdre en
ligne ce match et après cet incident il
est revenu il est revenu il a montré
qu'il était capable dans n'importe
quelle circonstance de déstabiliser
l'adversaire en tout cas de de ce
concentré de ce concentré quel que soit
enfin alors que bon kramnik lui a besoin
de conditions normales une passion de là
il ya quelqu'un qui s'amusait à
déconcentrer l'autre très fair play
ça fait partie de partie du ve
dans les autres sports si les
intimidations peut voir les matchs de
boxe avant il ya des intimidations iliad
est aussi des tentatives de déstabiliser
l'adversaire c'est vrai mais je crois
que jusqu'à présent dans les échecs les
richert l'a fait déjà fischer l'a fait
sans match contre ce parce qu' il a
imposé des conditions
oui c'est pas prévu initialement pour
pouvoir jouer il a obligé spassky par
exemple a joué dans une arrière salle
parce que il voulait pas qu'ils les
projecteurs ou et cameyrac ça le gêne et
c'est donc je sais pas si fichiers plus
est ce possible de tricherie non il n'ya
pas que ces tricheries non simplement
demander des conditions de jeu
différente oui non c'est vrai que les
joueurs ont quelquefois sont difficiles
mais un corps chinois il ya enfin 8% il
ya trois accusés le clan karpov
d'utiliser un parapsychologue oui mais
c'était pas vraiment de la tricherie
c'était des là il a mis en cause des
techniques d'intimidation c'est vrai que
il y avait un parapsychologue d'octobre
sugar qui étaient dans la salle et qui
étaient là pour réussir il ya les pulls
accusé de tricherie mais rossi s'est
peut-être fait pas vraiment de la
tricherie sur le jeu au truc dont je
pense pas que je pense que les joueurs
et surtout aucun joueur n'a accusé
tricherie son adversaire alors qu'il est
mené au score
oui c'est vrai et qu'il a mal joué en
plus moyen plus soit tout à fait une
opposition aux noms bizarres
en tout cas on y est 5-4 maintenant pour
topalov on croit que le match est plié
mais kramnik il reste quand même deux
fois les blancs et on va voir ce qu'il
va faire dans cette dixième partie face
du lac radical et blanc et idée m'a tout
de suite par le coût des quatre et on va
voir qu'après 4 6 déjà qu'ils diffèrent
un peu puisqu'on va a priori peut-être
un peu différé puisque après ces quatre
c'est le coup aussi ceux qui jouent et
et non pas et non pas la slave avec ses
6 centres cette fois c'est vrai que sur
des cas qu'il ya pas eu d 4d 5
voilà mes topalov via quand même deux
deux places et nouveautés importantes
avec les blancs 1
il n'a pas envie de montrer tout de
suite ce qu'il faut jouer avec les noirs
ou
peut-être que je vais vraiment quelque
chose de très fort pour le match est
donc c'est pour ça qu'il choisit il
choisit marrante à différentes il veut
jouer nîmes the beach il veut faire nul
moindre binam il veut faire dû
facilement pour éviter
de perdre son avantage de gaulle en fait
maintenant il veut il veut jouer pour
lui il veut jouer un gros bide amenons
qu'avec les noirs après kalyev trois des
cinq on est dans une ambiance
le ca me plais ici parce par cette
possibilité d'échanger ici de prise de
pions qui un pseudo d'hambye puisqu'on
peut être en général on n'arrive pas à
tenir le pion à ses quatre voilà après
g3 catalan donc là une erreur catalan
une verte un peu particulière du gambit
dame l'ouverture catalan puisqu'on veut
mettre le flou est fort quand même
classique pour crâner dans ce match oui
et non c'est une ouverture très
classique à une ouverture très classique
qui qui est très solide et qui permet
donc aux blancs de se développer de
manière standard avec le fou ou confiant
qu eto sur la casse g2 donc le fruit est
fort bien sûr g2 est un roc rapide donc
un développement de pièces rapide avec
le problème de ce pôle en évidemment
puisque c'est pas mal fou ici on a en a
plus la reprise naturelle par le fou
voilà ces pages et en force à la cram
mixer un plat seconde pièce c'est quand
même efficace foulée quatre échecs
voilà les deux classiques foot beckett
on va revenir comme sur foot des cats
c'est quand même une grande nouveauté
dans ce match c'est la première fois que
topalov refuse donc de jouer ce qu'on
appelle la catalane ouvertes
c'est-à-dire dans cette position après
g3 topalov film semble avait joué
souvent des procès car dans cette
position par exemple ses pensées car il
avait pris le pion et la chronique avec
joseph ou g2 et récupérer le pion plus
tard par damas cas d'échec la maca très
cher comme ces deux options
voilà donc il est parti c'était
avait continué de cette façon est la
taupe à l'offre veut cette fois joué ce
que l'on appelle une catalane fermé
c'est à dire que le pion des cinq
restent au centre donc il a peut-être
lui de son côté envie de tirer les
leçons de la défaite de la partie
d'avant de chroniques qui lui avait
abandonné le centre est pour cette
partie importante surtout et qu'il a
envie de il envie de faire match nul n'a
envie de faire match nul de prolonger
donc de prolonger son avantage au score
donc ils décident de jouer un truc
solide donc fou bekkat échec
c'est classique la réponse des blancs et
classique aussi est en fait le coup
après fawcett est normal c'est là qu'on
revient de 7
l'idée c'est qu'on se dit qu'après
l'échec ici le fonds fait a rien à faire
en d2 donc de toutes façons elle est mal
placée en fait oui
petite nuance oui pour éviter d'autres
développements plutôt de jouer il faut s
est tout de suite certes ici on pourrait
se dire je vous fous hausse est tout de
suite
fawcett et les noirs estime qu'il faut
c'est tout de suite est possible mais
n'aurait steam qu'après donc fou des
quatre fous des deux fosses est le fou
est quand même moins bien placés en d2
qui ne l'était en c1 voilà donc ça c'est
une petite gêne à l'hygiène en d2 c'est
une petite nuance donc c'est clair que
pour les pour pour les
amateurs qui sont pas trop spécialisées
la position ça peut paraître un peu
abstrait mais mais bon c'est une petite
mobilité une petite subtilité voilà de
toute façon y développe une pièce et le
fou en d2 on peut considérer que ce
n'est pas un développement utile donc il
faudra re bouger se fout plus tard donc
ça change pas grand chose à chamarande
fou j'ai deux petits rock classique
petit rock aussi et la c6 donc on rentre
quand même dans un chai maintenant qui
ressemble
ça ressemble à ce schéma ressemblent
pour les noirs là à la slave évidemment
mais avec j'ai trop fruit de sa rien à
voir c'est si le même type quand même de
structurer ce match on va décidément on
aura vu cette structure comme la
structure red pour la défense pour les
noirs c'est vrai que c'est la structure
à la mode actuellement quand on joue des
cartes soit on est des joueurs agressifs
qui échouent les stades yens soit on a
des joueurs qui place ses pions en d5
est souvent un procès civil à la menace
pour les noirs c'est vraiment de prendre
ses cadres et de jouer des cinq sans
doute essayer de tenir ses pions en se
fiant tracés possibles problèmes du sfo
évidemment qui peut avoir une belle
action sur la diagonale
c'est une possibilité c'est une
possibilité en tout cas lui cramique
ignorent cette possibilité en tout cas
faut être quatre donc maintenant ils
vont on voit bien que ce fonds était
obligé de rejouer
d'où l'idée des noirs tout à l'heure
maintenant cavalli bd c'est donc voilà
il choisit de ne pas rentrer dans l'est
dans la prise dans ces cas aussi et
toute façon sur pions procès car ce cas
tout simplement cavaliers 5 par exemple
cavalier de saint voilà tout simplement
peut-être qu'à 25 puisque le câble et le
pion est attaqué on voit que si les
noirs assez le protégé par le seul coup
qui protège les 5es lioret le pion c6 on
perdrait pioncer 6 attaqué par le le fou
et lecavalier et plus il n'est plus
protégé que par le cavalier hadders
voilà je vois qu'en régie on acquiesce
ça veut dire que ça suit là où dans les
rues la régie vidéo de diagonale tous
nos techniciens sont à pied d'oeuvre
donc le cavalier b17 à coup très solide
magnéto serge com
notre ami thierry comme disait notre
avis thierry sur antenne 2 sur france 2
alors faut être quatre cavaliers b17
donc on ne vient de voir pourquoi
dépenser quatre petits pas possible ne
marchait pas bon mais maintenant dans
ces deux il faut protéger maintenant
parce que parce qu'on n'a pas envie de
laisser de prendre pied en france et
quatre cavaliers des six peut-être qu'il
protégerait le client comme se veut donc
on est un coup classique
encore une fois à 5,25 dams et de aussi
kiki qui prépare un développement tour
enfin qui coordonne les tours on va dire
sauf si un oeil sur la case au théâtre
starr qu'après un canal i b d2 où vous
pourrez jouer aux 4 carmen la poussée
que veulent faire les blancs oui tout à
fait je l'aï veulent quand même essayer
de casser ce force entre noirs tôt ou
tard par jouer en juin la pousser le cas
donc la dame ces deux à la fois protège
ses 4es à un oeil aussi sur la case de 4
donc ça peut être utile et là assène ne
faut pas l'offre qui est un coup et open
of qui n'a pas envie de jouer les lignes
classiques comme puisque elles ont
tendance à donner un petit avantage aux
blancs à c'est assez agréable en plus ça
conviendrait très bien c'est une crainte
ni style de kramnik d'ailleurs cette
ouverture
il faut quand même avouer pour l'instant
c'est un choix curieux c'est un choix
curieux la part de topalov puisque
topaloff est quand même plus habitués
aux positions dynamique et quand même et
on aurait plutôt vu jouer le fameux la
fameuse catalane ouvertes à l'accueil en
france et 4 mais comme il l'a jouée
fermé il avait une idée en tête
et là c'est le début de son idée à 5 il
décide déjà 2 2
de prendre un peu d'espacé les dames on
voit que le pion à ça quand même
contrôler la case bekkat et a fait cette
case ici donc il prend un peu d espace
il prépare un contrat les dames c'est
donc c'est une idée particulière il a
une idée particulière de tours d un aux
coûts de développement
sortez un standard comme autrefois pour
soutenir ce pion ce temps des quatre ans
or la tour aussi sur une sur une colonne
ouverte à celle un peu vite donc suite à
quoi donc topalov a joué le coup kailash
il veut échanger se foutent menace
deschamps 10 ou non par le cavalier on
est tout à fait donc il veut prendre le
fou qui avait les âges soit le fou ne va
pas les blancs n'ont pas envie de donner
leurs food qui ramène le fou sur la case
c1
c'est injuste quand c'est pas ça ne va
pas trouver meilleure case en fait
kramnik on voit ce choix du mal à
trouver d'autres cases en g5y les
emprises du foot adam évidemment raciste
en parlant de paille elle tient
évidemment le 5 ces emprises des
cavaliers des 6es emprise donc c'est à
des cases envisageable il resterait
cette case
alors soit des deux mais on voit bien
que des deux bouches la tour 1 fillon il
était déjà en d2 tout à l'heure donc on
n'a pas envie de remettre en d2 et enrc
3 et bloquerait l'avancée du pion oui
tout à fait donc donc la seule à ce qui
reste c'est de la ramener à la maison
voilà tout simplement bonne case doit
préparer
on peut même jeu cavalli ces trois
quelque fois accablant de cette position
qu'avait laissé 3 et le gaz après après
phocéen après phocéen après phocéen donc
intéressé 3 et 4 juin 4 parce que le
pion c4 n'est pas toujours prenable donc
phocéen c'est le cookie
qui ne dérange pas l'ordre des pièces le
foot est très mal placé sur ses seins
mais le cavalier mal placé sur h56
lecavalier h
revenez avait l'idée de revenir sur la
case apsys là les plans pourraient
continuer différemment en plaçant
peut-être leur cavalier sur ces trois
pour jouer le cadre alors que lorient
psg 5 aussi où le flou sur la cage des
sags
mais oui oui tout à fait alors b5 donc
là topalov ross la question qui ont ces
quatre maintenant qu'est ce que tu fais
tu avances tu prends fait quelque chose
et la chronique évolutive et je prends
en aux centres bessin b5 c'est un coût
important aussi c'est qu'on responsable
c'est c'est le coût qui justifie le coût
est sain qui a donc c'est l'idée de
topalov topalov donc décide de
s'installer complètement halal dame
allèles dame comme ça il y aura pas de
jallet dame ça va se passer au centre et
ça c'est c'est une idée importante c'est
dire que la cie où les blancs jouent un
coup comme ces cinq au lieu de prendre
les noirs dans sa place ici dans cette
position aurait la possibilité de jouer
un coup comme f5 verrouiller le sens
pour verrouiller le servir verrouille
elle s'en tenir le centre la case en
case la case de kde et avec une position
très très très solide c'est pour ça que
chronique a décidé de prendre le pire
des cinq d'accord donc après c'est
prendre des 5 c'est prendre les 5 et
bien kramnik prend les grands moyens
maintenant pour profiter d'autant que ce
clavier et sur la zone et contrôle par 4
il veut tout de suite ouvrir la position
pour son fou j'ai deux oui il veut il
veut que ce fou joue son rôle à plein
d'un kilo pour avec le cas tout de suite
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir une adam sur ces
deux maintenant qu'ils contrôlent bien 4
et après pions prend 1,4 logique aussi
d'apprendre 4on un tueur isolé pour les
blancs ici on est bien on a quand une
belle batterie adam
fu chi contre totalement cette grande
diagonale est notamment déjà tout de
suite attaqué à tour on a bougé de
pièces sont à gauche de pièces donc les
voilà les peut on va pouvoir à tout
moment assez facilement aussi jouer des
cinq pour échanger ce pion si si
nécessaire autour des 8
alors juste un petit piège quand même à
mon fait bon c'est pas très important
mais par un peu après dames 4
on pourrait envisager le coût d'un v6
donc on pourra envisager sur coup la
dame p 6 alors c'est un choix curieux
puisque finalement après d'investis adam
prend 1,8 mg est sûre quand même il ya
une tour donc on donnerait une tour mais
après dame prend 1,8 il ya une astuce
qui piège c'est qu'on peut je fous
bessette et la dame éprise et la dame
n'a plus de cases et la tour donc en
fuite va pouvoir prendre la dame
enfin il faut c'est plutôt la dame qui
va sacrifier sur la tour anglade va
s'appuyer sur la tour on a pris deux
tours pour une dame
voilà avec des compensations et mais
grosso même v6 ya un coût qui gagne qui
est beaucoup plus clair ces cavaliers g5
donc ça c'est un petit coup amusant
puisque la dame qui est sur eux quatre
attaques la tour et le curage sa
talonnade à menace matt donc et la tour
pour parer le mat c'est simple il faut
prendre le cavalier simplement on a
comparé le match mais maintenant la dame
prend la tour et il n'est plus question
de jouer fou 17 puisque risquions ya le
fou voilà la case bessette est contrôlé
par le fuji deux brabants bien vu l'adap
progrès font 17 et ce serait gagnant
donc belle belle astuce à avoir calculé
voilà une petite astuce mais bon
le coût normal c'est tour des huit
tombes et 8 pour tout simplement
installer une pièce donc sur 17 et
contrôler la case centrale fallait
enlever la cour évidente de l'attak donc
alors c'est pour ça que kramnik lui joue
tout de suite d'un me 2 voilà et en même
temps une petite taille sur le cavalier
là il peut y avoir des idées comme
cavalier ou cinq attaquants lecavalier
h5
attention quand même ça va être un motif
fameuse dame joue essentiellement c'est
pour pas encombrer la contrainte et
canal pour sortir de cette diagonale or
ce que fout bessette et ai été le coup
que les noirs envie de vous envie de
jouer la taupe elle choisit de jouer
tout de suite cavaliers à chécy efficy
donc d'enlever ce cavalier un peu de
cette petite découverte et de le ramener
vers le centre surtout contre l'erika
centrale à lecavalier était hors jeu
donc il faut le replacer au centre
voilà n'ont pas oublié de replacer ces
pièces vous échec très très important
quand on a une pièce mal placé il n'ya
pas s'il ya pas de coups forcé et bien
il faut toujours à ramener ses pièces
sur des bonnes cases fouet f4 donc ça y
revient avec catherine en plus qu al
ahly a décidé de wii le jeu classique
mais il place ses pièces en fonction de
jeu adverse mais il attaque la toho
toujours toujours dans l'idée d'occuper
les cases stratégiques dont classe un
fonds f4 qui contrôle le centre qui
c'est le meilleur développement du foot
c'est à dire que trawick a réussi son
début
gagner attention avec la ce fou à jouer
quand même plusieurs coups il venu en d2
f4 revenu en c1 et maintenant il se
retrouve de nouveau en f4 donc il a pas
mal voyagé mais à chaque fois pour des
raisons bien bien clair et là tout de
suite il ya une menace sur la tour oui
enfin pour l'instant le débat dans
l'ouverture de n'est pas fini je crois
qu'il a il a gagné l'ouverture il n'a
pas encore gagné l'ouverture je crois
que le débat va se terminer
non moi je dis là il en a pas il a
parfois raison ouverture par exemple
comme il ya deux parties annoncent dans
la 8ème colle mal à la haye où il avait
complètement raté son truc là si on peut
pronostiquer les choses à ce moment de
la partie
ça sera dans le pire des cas pour les
blancs le match nul voilà l'un pire des
cas et ils peuvent jouer pour le gain
alors évidemment topal enfin pas envie
de mettre sa tour sur case blanche
puisque elle serait en vis-à-vis du fou
d'ailleurs qu'après on peut faire bondir
le but de lecavalier par exemple attaque
en même temps la tour ce qui peut poser
des soucis donc topalov c'est pourquoi
tout pâle joue tout simplement le seul
couple il reste pour b6 du tour b6 un
coût qui est pas mal puisque la tour
donc tu aurais pas si mal mais ce n'est
pas ça elle défend le top-5 et elle
permet ou fous ces huit de se développer
sur la case baissait toujours un oeil
sur pied sec important puisque la dame
et laon c'est vrai que on apprend qu'il
faut placer les tours sur l'école
ouverte maison le développement noir ne
le permet pas point cavaliers ou cinq
maintenant donc ça hisser leur donc le
fou se réveille voilà ensuite cavalier
de 50 al ahly centrale un avant-poste
donc pour
comprenez pas mal de cases il a donc
contrôler la casse et 6 aussi important
oui bien sûr ça fait et menaces qu'elle
allait cesser ses lacets qu'avait laissé
six par exemple un cours imaginer un
coup comme le h6 inscrits immense et
c'est une grosse menace qui avait laissé
six attaques
la dame est le fou mais dans ce cas les
protégés parfois par le fou on peut pas
le prendre de l'atome et vannes devrait
bouger sur les cases par exemple sur
dames élites on prendrait le fou par
exemple tout simplement pour énorme il y
aurait des menaces et peut-être même
plus grave
on pourrait on peut prendre le fou
évidemment bien sûr mais on peut aussi
jouer poussé cet attaquant la tour et
l'appliquent à 7 tours oui donc là c'est
vrai qu'il fait voilà ces images dans la
fosse et 7 et il ya plus de quatre pour
cette tour parce que par exemple
qu'est-ce qui se compose retour à suisse
par exemple
voilà maintenant le pion étant prise
voilà et surtour bessette
on va se retrouver avec le fameux
vis-à-vis fou tour donc mais pourrait
faire cavaler premier produit 7 qui est
donc une attaque de tours à la
découverte voilà on attaquera la tour 1
celui donc voilà donc c'est déjà une
menace donc c'est pourquoi
topalov empêche ces menaces par cas les
dessins qui bouche la des modèles du fou
et la cram ni que maintenant saute sur
cette occasion il
pour pour rentrer dans une
dans une une petite combinaison fait une
petit changement de position on peut
dire en combinaison pas vraiment mes
techniques
un choix stratégique choix stratégiques
je vais expliquer un petit peu la
situation là on voit qu'on a donc on a
un cavalier donc et sur la case des 5
c'est un bel avant postes aussi pour le
cavalier donc il ya un avant poste pour
les blancs géants menacent pont de ça on
reste de doubler le cavalier et un an
des 5 mai donc ce cavalier l'a déjà veut
prendre attaque le fou attaque le four
f4 mais celui-là tacle fouet ce cadre
qu'il prend elle fout et les les blancs
sera obligé de reprendre du pied on ici
et on veut le doublé aussi on veut jouer
la doublait on veut jouer car alice est
ce qu'elle est c'est tf6 peut-être aussi
on peut doubler les cavaliers il peut
doubler les cavaliers donc et après
continuer le développement de manière
classique donc dans cette position après
cavaliers des 5
c'est pas si simple que ça pour les pour
les blancs et c'est vrai que krainik a
quand même dire a dû réfléchir à ce
moment là puisque c'est quand même il
fait un choix important c'est que il se
débarrasse donc de sa paire de fou il se
débarrasse de sa paire de foudre qu'il
prend avec le fou g2 lecavalier en d5
voilà et ça ça c'est un coup responsable
c'est un coup très responsable c'est ce
qu'on enlève quand même un protecteur
des cases blanches près du roi des cases
blanches près du roi
ça peut être ça peut vraiment être très
très dangereux et on donne une autre
dimension à la la position d'un côté on
se débarrasse un peu de cette faiblesse
est un doublé qui va purement isolé
pardon dans un endroit isolé de même le
pur adverse qui remet frais il faut
quand même pas faut pas généraliser un
pion un pion des cats ce n'est pas une
faiblesse un puriste de classe et quand
même si on est isolé le pur isolé n'est
pas une faiblesse le purise hall est un
pur isolée avant tout c'est à dire que
dans une position a priori isolée est
une faiblesse lorsque les pièces se sont
échangées et qu'il est bien bloquée
voilà c'est dans cette position il ya
une tour qui est sur la colonne des il
ya un cavalier qui peut brouiller
éventuellement revenir sur ces trois ya
un fou qui est sûre j'ai deux ce pion
quand même qui
bon l'avancé et surprotégé n'est pas
faible sa région qui est dynamique pour
cette position qui est peut être en
reste avéré voilà sur le long terme ça
peut ça peut s'avérer sur le long terme
mais je ne crois pas que cramique et
peur de se débarrasser de ce pur moi
mais c'est surtout que dans cette
position le gavrian d5 est très très
bien placées ont très bien pas s'il doit
prendre
il doit prendre avec le fou est encore
une fois donc
si gravelines n'a pas vu ça après coup
qu'on descend les rendant ainsi kramnik
n'a pas vu de solutions claires on peut
dire que topalov pourrait gagner la
phase de l'ouverture puisqu'il arrive
quand même quelque part à déstabiliser
un peu le jeu en obtenant la paire de
fou alors que mais là tout de suite il
ya quand même un coût qui qui va quand
même provoqué une série quand même
tactique intéressante et et pour les
crucial c'est le coup tout simplement
car les c3 puisque ce cas ralliée
attaque à la fois le cube et 5 avec la
dame et aussi le pion de dessin we came
sa raquette et le seul coup mais leur
logique le coup le coût plus important
de la partie n'a pas encore été joué
cavalier c3 est un coût de développement
et le coût de développement naturel
puisque s'ils ont joué un coup comme
cavalier d2 on n'attaque pas les les
faiblesses et l'adversaire pourrait soit
échangé les cavaliers
5 soit peut-être une cavalière 6 par
exemple et continuer son développement
tu as fait donc votre terminal sans
travail car les c3 et le coût normal
évidemment cavaliers le 6 nouveaux
protégés surtout le pion des cinq pour
la viande plus auraient attaqué la cour
l'a évidemment j'ai envoyé des avions
passé si on prend 1,5
oui c'est cavalli avait pris le sac y
aurait eu des pros le 5 mars on comprend
leur cavalier prendre cinq ans ça sera
une grosse faute très certainement
puisque après pu en prendre 5
on voit que la torche au réveil face aux
pions et demi maintenant tout est en
prison voilà ça va être très dur on va
perdre le pion d1 principalement au
risque de perdre son option tout à fait
donc il a joué cavalier pts 6 on préfère
donner l'autre pions cas les petits dons
qui donne ce pion quand même là tout de
suite donc mais on va voir que il a des
compensations après calais prend des 5 x
6 et on voit bien que ce cavalier cloud
et maintenant parce qu'il ya la dame
derrière donc si ce cas les bouge et
tout de suite il est en prise de la tour
et du fou encore une fois un coup forcé
à 4 à 4 coups forcé mais mais plaisant à
jouer toujours plaisant à jouer on
protège le nôtre avant postes logique
et maintenant après cavaliers aux quatre
voilà il ya cavaliers ou quatre pour
venir c'est éventuellement sur la case
des six yamasawa ses possibilités de
carrière des six est un cavalier qui est
bien placé aux six ans quatre danses
possibilité de venir en d6 parce
qu'évidemment une fois que lecavalier
serait sur la case des six ce cavalier
la wii
donc petit problème de flèches
une fois que lecavalier serait sur la
case des six on verrait qu'il attaque
donc le fameux cavaliers en b 5 voilà
qui est cloué par le fou et qui a aussi
attaqué par le rajouter de la force sur
le cloud et voilà on veut rajouter donc
des pièces pour pour attaquer la pièce
louée est évidemment récupérer le fameux
pions qu'on a en moins donc ça c'est
l'idée de cavaliers e4 et là dans cette
position donc radnic drôme agents écran
il trouve le coût normal qu'ils
continuent la partie mais probablement
le premier cookies qui posent de
sérieuses difficultés au noir le premier
coup le premier coup dur on va dire vrai
coup dur on va le voir tout de suite
tour des c1 alors étonnant on dirait
jean luc parce que si on veut mettre à
l'or fin d'un côté on comprend l'idée de
ce coup cc tour déjà se met sur une
colonne ouverte donc toujours positif
ensuite la casse et 6 est disponible
pour le cavalier qui attaquera la fois
la dame et le fou sans compter que la
dame ici on est peut-être un oeil dessus
ah oui tiens sens et de grossman à ce
qui est quand même une menace contre une
menace qui par la menace qu'ils avaient
des six voilà un plus et ça parle à
manosque avait décidé sans citer les six
lacs a laissé six mois là on va le voir
tout de suite si karl et des six
maintenant tout de suite
et bien tout simplement cavaliers ces
six attaques à la fois la da est le fou
et avec la dame ici qui attaquent le fou
donc le yahia perte il faut redonner la
tour en fait voilà donc ton c1 qui est
le cookie par déjà la menace principale
de l'adversaire pour se reposer la
question quand même jean-luc sur cette
idée sur ses tics cette idée toujours de
garder la colonne ci pourquoi ne pas
jouer des tours à ses seins quelle est
la différence
la différence entre tours d'essai en
étant assez ans
je pense qu'il y aurait il y aurait
probablement ont peu près la même suite
que dans la partie mais ce qu'on n'a pas
tout simplement perdu l'oeil sur le pion
à simple lagardère à deux reprises ici
non mais il faut voir sur le long terme
et la tour de toute façon si on regarde
la position avec la tour en a on imagine
qu'avec toutes ces pièces cloud et il y
aura enfin avec ce cavalier clouant b5
là je vais enlever
je je vais enlever les petites flèches
donc avec le cavalier courir sur la case
b5
ici on imagine que tout va s'échanger
quelques ans à 4 va va prendre ce
cavalier en bessin enfin que vous va
prendre le cavalier d'abord équivalent
échanges multiples et et puis on va
récupérer le pion sur pc pour les noirs
les noirs voire le punk en fait alors
pourquoi enlever une tour qui plus tard
pour être qu'un pion on pourrait garder
cette tour sur cette case et amener le
retour sur cette case et essayer de
rendre cette tour active puisque c'est
vrai que là en d1
la tour est la tour défend uniquement le
pion des quatre c'est pas qu'ils aient
bloqué qui bloquait pas blindé on veut
on peut pas dire que c'est son salaire
place c'est sa meilleure position là
donc c'est important parce que souvent
on peut se tromper dans le maniement des
tours de savoir laquelle il faut la
mettre
donc ça devrait kozhaya le le critère
c'est bien soutien à 5 on apprend à se
développer donc les
l'éclat tient d'abord à développer ces
pièces mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
positions garder il faut faire des choix
dans le bon développement et qu'on les
deux tours sont liés choisir la bonne
course et c'est un très bon coup c'est
pas facile
voilà donc la tournée c'est le bon temps
des siens le bon coup et pas l'autre
tour et après dames 8 logique de topalov
il augmente la pression sur des scènes
qui menacent vous prend voilà devant et
j'aurais peut-être d'en prendre
il veut récupérer pions voilà et la
chronique trouve un joli coup logique
aussi pour ses 7 me contre attaque sur
le fou maintenant imaginons un échange
généralisé food rend si on prend on
récupère le cuir avec les noirs dame
prend eh bien ça marcherait pas à cause
de d'apprendre tout reprendra mais à la
fin le fou est en prise voilà grenelle
année une pièce
donc il faut bien tout calcul est
évidemment de se lancer dans ce genre de
des changes généralisée dont sept qui
répond également un principe important
c'est tout simplement la tour sur la 7e
il faut tafer faut pas oublier que tour
sur la 7ème c'est quand même c'est quand
même plein de cible adverse là on voit
quand même parmi les pièces il ya quand
même quatre pièces adverse sur 7
cette septième rangée en plus avec le
cavalier on peut toujours imaginer une
attaque sur f 7 et puis cette tourelle
est très gênante agir d'ailleurs quand
on apprend le matin avec deux tours on
sait très bien qu'il faut qu'une tour
sur la septième et une tour sur la
huitième donc la tour sera septième pour
mater le roi s'est jamais enfin on peut
toujours imaginer des tactiques qui
pourrait arriver à n'importe quel moment
donc tour ici c'est dangereux s'attaque
le fou et topalov toujours on a toujours
envie de jouer ce genre de coups de
tours toujours actif et topalov juifs ou
des vis tu veux chasser l'acteur et
cookies allaire qui a l'air de sauver la
position de sauver la position puisque
j'enlève le fou de la position j'attaque
la tour et il va rester cette prise ici
qui va gagner ce pion mais mais après
tour à 7
eh bien on voit que suite aux échanges
qui pourrait y avoir un b 5 sélections à
5 qui peut aussi être en prise mais il y
aurait le fou y aurait le fou les
réponses dit que on dit qu'il est temps
pour topalov alors est ce que ton grave
pourrait faire les échanges ici pour
récupérer son pion alors là donc ça
c'est la position critique de la partie
c'est la position donc qui aussi on
critique qui mérite donc d'être un peu
plus détaillée donc
dans cette position donc topalov à la
possibilité de récupérer son pion ouais
alors ça c'est le cookie d'ivoire il a
la possibilité de récupération en plus
il faut qu'ils trouvent une solution
rapide parce qu'il commençait à voir des
menaces désagréable
je sais pas éventuellement le cavalier
qui pourrait venir ici faire une
fourchette
ouais ouais bah oui c'est fait un plein
plein de choses désagréables c'est assez
désagréable
il va falloir donc réagir et donc la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est que
se passe-t-il après fou qu'on v5
oui je te pose la question où en bessin
évidemment on reprend avec le pion mis
sur dans le premier set
donc on échange les dames oui donc voilà
et là apparemment d'après les analyses
donc dans cette position constate qu'il
ya une égalité parfaite qui a obtenu et
y'a rien n'y a rien il y a un petit
avantage significatif c'est la tour sur
la 7e
bien sûr et un cavalier actifs eux mêmes
puisque un petit avantage on peut dire
un avantage significatif mais il faut
l'exploiter
parce que en échange la les noirs
attaque le pion de d2 donc dans cette
position mais il faut tout simplement
jouer un coup un coup sobre pour le
qualifier de sobres oui puisque c'est le
cas il faut tout simplement jouer pour
ac toi de défendre avec la tour ce plan
n'est rien n'est fait voilà là rien
n'est fait rien n'est fait pour
l'instant mais mes amis davantage
il ya une pression c'est le style de
kramnik sa musique est un joueur
extrêmement sobre qui aime bien un
tiennent bien avoir les des micros
avantages qu'ils talonnent cumul qu'on
l'a vu jouer tour des c1
donc là il pourrait jouer pour à 2 pour
défendre le pion car la pression sur la
scène qu'on peut pas prendre à cause du
fou est là pour toujours sur la scéne
vienne cavailles actifs qui peut sauter
en 10 ans cède 1,17 pour attaquer à tour
qui peut éventuellement devenir sur la
case 6,6 aussi willy apparaître des
thèmes la marge de manoeuvre des noirs
est limitée par exemple à dans cette
position si ils placent leurs fous sur
la case b6 on pourrait envisager un
clouage du fou ouais le flou et la
menace
si ces clous et puisqu'à la tour
derrière un ac c'est désagréable si les
noirs dans cette mission pour se libérer
et jouer un coup comme tours 8
le clouage cette fois on pourrait
l'imaginer peut-être ici souvent à vite
et bien sûr la loi j'ai on pourrait
l'imaginer une coche du fou qui
permettra aux cavaliers venir là et
d'attaquer le fou ouais enfin plein de
petits inconvénients
le coût principal pour essayer de se
libérer dans cette position après le
petit couteau à deux ce serait f6
attaquant de cavani attaquant cavaliers
libérant un peu le roi du vin du couloir
aussi voilà donc le cavalier vient là le
fou vient sur v6 obligé avec cette fois
quelques astuces puisque si on joue
tourbe et 7 dans cette position on peut
éventuellement proposer un échange de
tour par trois sets
et là on a grâce à ce petit coup m6 on a
la possibilité donc s'il vient là on
vient là on vient là donc on a la
possibilité d'échanger les caissettes
garder les meilleures pièces
ça peut être égale d'accord ça peut être
égal mais donc on va revenir donc là
c'est un petit peu ce qui est bien
prendre une balle of là dans cette
position dans cette partie il peut ainsi
dire est que la nulle au mieux
exactement
mais il ya le coup cavaliers 7 le
cavalier 7 qui pose des problèmes parce
que le roi
si le roi fui sur la casa suite après
ton pc est mal placée le roi est hors
jeu complètement jeu et le clouage et
désagréable cette fois puisque cette
fois on ne peut plus jouer au tours fc
il y aura un maître du couloir là si on
joue le coup qu'on a joué tout à l'heure
ça n'aurait aucun sens puisqu'il y
aurait ce fameux échec et or et mat du
couloir
voilà le fath riche couloir est très
jolie donc après roy f7 maintenant on
joue tour 17
le roi essaie de monter au centre mais
cette position est difficile à
stabiliser puisque le roi a dû quitter
son rock
ce qui n'est pas forcément un mal mais
il ya des faiblesses à nouveau et la
tour aura quand même quelques cibles à
l'aide à caen allait droit et après un
coup comme cavalier c6 on attaque à la
fois ses cibles là et et le pion à son
un petit peu qu'ils ont à 5 en plus on
peut rajouter à ça la menace aussi fous
ces sept pour
profitez du courage du fou c'est
terrible parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de thèmes
ça fait beaucoup de choses il t'aime
c'est compliqué mais
c'est difficile d'aller dans cette
direction et topalov a pris une décision
différente
il a choisi de jouer directement f6 il a
joué m6 tout de suite
et là c'est la caf joue f6 tout de suite
va dire que c'est la gaffe on peut dire
que oui on peut dire que c'est la gaffe
on peut dire quelque part que il croyait
il n'a pas cru du tout dans ses chances
là à ce moment là ici il a bien vu que
l'on récupère le pion il allait être mal
donc il joue m6 pour tenter quelque
chose qui tente quelque chose mais c'est
drôle et on va voir la combinaison que
kramnik maintenant à vue il a tout vu
notre ami travnik puisque l'après il
joue cavalier 17 et ça y est il ya une
fourchette de 10 à 10 la fameuse
pochette double tour mais on va voir que
bon on peut parer cette fourchette mais
qu'à la faim chronique va s'en sortir
avec avantage puisque après tout rêve 7
qui propre propose un vis-à-vis tout
retour et le cavalier ne protège pas
vraiment puisque le fou un tacle à
d'avancé rien de compliqué monde vers un
petit peu plus tard donc à vivre à
l'abri sa cavale et prendre des six
tours province elle tout reprend la
scène hélas le cavalier est cloué on ne
peut pas puisque le fou attaque la dame
mais tout simplement on récupère le pion
central des singles et ça c'est énorme
c'est un gros pions puisque c'est le
pion central
donc on peut dire que ça y est les
blancs ont pris un avantage décisif pas
complètement qu'en fait un très gros
avantage
oui mais la position doivent être encore
plus clair dans deux trois coups puisque
là alors quand même il ya la séquence
qui suit tournée des lanettes donc qu'à
l'ère une bonne solution dans un cadre
attaque le cavalier et puis on va être
prenable à cause du fait que ce cas les
deux ne protège toujours pas en cause du
fou qui attaquent la dame donc je
regardais les décès seraient allés
revient pour un placement classique
cloud lecavalier a eu 4 et se qualifie
cloud est maintenant assez clouage
contre clouage puisque la ses cavaliers
s'il bouge évidemment c'est la dame qui
serait emprise donc ça serait énorme
donc il fallait voir tout ça et après
tout reprendre des quatre plateaux bien
sûr eu un tour ou un donc la menace
c'est évidemment car les plans cavaliers
gagne tout simplement une pièce et après
f5 et bien le coup suivant
decraene nico ries ps que l'or est ce
que cramique aurait pas joué le coup
aura pas pu jouer
jean-luc le coup f3 oui mais je crois
qu'il n'a pas n'a pas envie de laisser
quoi que ce soit on a vu mieux il a fait
mieux que ça en fait oui la f3 déjà bien
d'une pièce en l'air l'impression de
gagner une pièce puisque ce cavalier
peut pas bouger il est cloué f3 gagne
peut-être une pièce mais mais je crois
que dans cette position il préfère jouer
technique joue donc le coup aurait des
coûts il y aura des menaces avec four b6
peut-être attention le roi donc il a
préféré jouer technique kramnik il a vu
une suite encore plus clair choix qui
les complète il a joué dame ces deux
joutes mc2 ce cavalier cloud et c'est le
problème c'est le problème des bleus des
noirs ce cavalier cloud et la tour
maintenant est attaquée puisque le
cavalier ça y est ne n'ai plus couru
contre la dame donc il est actif dont
qui menace tout simplement câble les
propos d'anne une pour ce qui est cette
fois le jeu aux créatifs de topalov en
quelquefois il récompenser les cette
fois il a été il a été puni puisque son
sa stratégie n'était pas bonne et après
deux saisons on se rend bien compte
puisque la tour descartes est attaqué
par cavalier p 5
on peut aller ce tour c'est ça la
question mais il ya une menace
la taille de la tour descartes deux
menaces avec l'hommage du cavalier et a
menacé la vallière franck cavallier
tout reprend avec grosse attaque directe
le monde et même f 3 1 tout toujours
possibilité est donc la taupe à l'ofas
est ce qu'il y aura au total auraient pu
jouer un coup comme tour 17 avaient tout
simplement un coup comme f3 et voilà ça
y est le cavalier floués par la tour
avec la dernière ces morts ne peut pas
parler cette menace donc il a joué tour
b4 topalov voilà mais déjà ça y est
grosse combinaison de cramique on peut
la revoir quand même depuis le début
c'est suite à l'erreur de topalov et 6
et là quelle erreur toute la combinaison
était calculée par kramnik qu'à valider
cette double attaque tour eiffe cette
logique on prend la tour on comprend la
logique on prend le pion central et même
si les noirs semblent le récupérer par
tour 17
on voit que la petite combine kramnik
maintenant va jouer sur le clouage de ce
cavalier
voilà une fois que l'option a disparu et
bien ce cavalier le nom est
effectivement prises
il va gagner du temps avec cavalli ces
trois attaques lecavalier donc force
tout reprend des quatre qui est possible
il ne peut pas prendre à cause du fou
qui est à craindre et après tour qui
remet la pression sur le cavalier est
évidemment par transparence sur la dame
qui est derrière
même le coup et cinq ne permet pas de
parent et dames c2 qui attaquent à la
fois la tour laisse la tour en vis-à-vis
de la dame est donc prêt par la poussée
froid topal joue encore tourbe et 4
octobre et après il a maintenant crâne
il va entrer une combinaison de
simplification encore plus encore plus
clair
oui là il joue cavalier des cinq donc
tous cas d'aller des 5
et voilà cette attaque est l'atout
ouvrir le tour à la thérapie de cazilhac
il a enfermé la tour la tour n'applique
gaz
il garde le clouage sur le cavalier en
plus de gardes et moi c'est ton à plus
de cases c'est ici l été en prise
évidemment par la dame
ici aussi ici n'en parlons même pas
égales qui ont évidemment là tout de
suite j'ai appris du cavalier l'année la
dame est la dernière case à ceux
disponibles à sa disposition cd4 mais
elle sera emprisonnée du cavaly médoc la
clac aurait prise topaloff
avait l'intention de sacrifier cette
tour puisque de toute façon hyper d'une
pièce garder une pièce vous préfère
donner la qualité que l'état donné la
qualité donc là après que des singles
il prend le cavalier en bessin qu'il
faut prendre pour prendre cinq à prendre
les 5 d'en prendre 5
voilà donc il a sacrifié évidemment il
reprendre la dame pour se sortir du club
sinon il l'aurait pris encore f3 dans la
tête
non seulement il sort du courageux mais
éventuellement il peut toujours préparé
un petit peu de contre jeu sur sur le
roi de perse puisque la dame b 5 qui
pourrait venir sur les gaz à fond et la
chronique continuer à simplifier la
position maintenant il est gagnant avec
la qualité car l essai c'est ce qu'avait
laissé c'est un excellent coup qui va
tout simplement lui permettre de ces
dossiers et d'éliminer la paire de
fouilles dominé un de ces deux fous là
donc là et finalement la paire de fou
dans cette partie n'aura pas été en
l'honneur chose qui est plutôt rare
puisque si on se souvient de la partie
d'avant la paire de fouetter royal est
là dans cette partie la paire de fou a
subi la pression de
on dira le jeu des cavaliers et le jeu
des pièces cloud est aussi et là on va
avoir une petite combinaison de des
changes en fait de chroniques
tout à fait marrant tout à fait amusante
c'est à dire que kramnik veut absolument
échange de la paire de fou donc tous par
là veulent éviter avec dams et 4 et bien
maintenant si tu me prends la dame je
reprends du fou et hop je garde quand
même à perdre fou donc ta qualité ça va
pas être facile que ça de gagné mais
crâne kuduro m non mais moi j'ai vu plus
loin
dale d1 alors superbe coup on va me
verrez un coup exceptionnel très joli
coup pourquoi alors parce que d'abord un
bon coup mais mais en fait tu laisses tu
laisses le client prisons secrètes en
crise du fouet et de la dame est mieux
protégé que par le fond donc topalov
prend le fouet la chronique a tout vu
superbe qu'on ne craint ni date 17
énorme puisqu'il menace à la fois matt
tout simplement dame maths on est que le
roi ce rythme at il serait un échec de
la dame
ici tout les cas seraient prises y
compris la dame est lacazette cette part
là donc c'est un math de dames menacé et
en même temps et mais en fait on va
récupérer le fou puisque le foot
attaquer donc on peut pas parler à la
fois le mat et le fou donc c'est une
combinaison qui permet simplement de
faire un échange
oui mais il ya beaucoup de leçons donc
aux échecs de contenu ce qu'on appelle
des combinaisons de simplification c'est
tout simplement le jeu technique le jeu
le livre de chroniques
le jeu qui simplifie la position qu'ils
évitent les complications et qui après
on voit bien que il simplifie tout on
obtient toutes les cases noires le pion
à 5 va se retrouver indéfendable et la
pression va s'écrouler rapidement
soutient ont du mal à défendre et après
h 6 pour se garder une petite fenêtre
voilà marc hellman fameuse fenêtre et on
prend de la dame avec évidemment de la
dame pourquoi parce qu'on attaque à la
fois la dame dont vous menace un échange
entre guillemets et aussi on a un oeil
sur le tueur à 5 dans mes cadeaux
topalov qui veut garder en vie dans ce
joli coup non il coûtait 1 puisqu'il
attaque à la fois la tour et
logis mais bon mais après d'amd 8 ça y
est échec voilà il est chargé d'âmes
après ces histoires de toilettes je
crois pas que chronique avec de
l'électro voilà donc la dame de huit
échecs donc très joli il va rentrer dans
la danse qu'on appelle une finale avec
une qualité net de plus et ça ça suffit
largement
étant donné que lille reste encore des
pions sur le côté c'est puis on le
soutient b 12.5 ça suffit largement pour
gagner on va voir quand même la suite
technique de ce gain il va durer encore
quelques coups après d'apprendre v8 faut
prendre les huit donc là il ya une
qualité de plus il ya une belle qualité
1 à 7 tours là qui fait la différence et
une face aux cavaliers choses
importantes comme a expliqué donc
chez les spectateurs c'est que dans
cette position après vous prendrez 8
donc une qualité de plus en général ces
gagnants
mais là il ya encore un facteur qui se
rajoute au matériel c'est le fait qu'il
reste un pion et qui reste un pion de
chaque côté al alaoui est sûre il reste
ça voilà c'est sinon ça aurait pas si
c'est pas si facile et si on enlève le
pion à sa question b2 la position peut
être tenable
en tous cas de manière peu comme une
forteresse voilà ce qu'on amène à une
forte mais le problème c'est que la tour
change facilement de colonne donc elle
peut facilement aller sur la colonne a
été attaquée cette cible ajoutons à ça
s'il est donc mobiliser une pièce à la
défense et après on va activer
éventuellement le roi si nécessaire
alors et le pion à 5 donc il y aura été
le coup nouveau et le pion trop quoi
finalement le parti puisque ses pions
qui va être perdu tout à fait alors
après deux quarts à l'idée de qui est un
peu insidieux qui menacent cavaillès 3
évidemment avec fourchette
alors évidemment kramnik se laisse pas
prendre au piège pour le moment
t'auras 1 et la sai et pouf j'attaque le
pion à 5 voilà c'est les coûts de
l'ecoute désespoir on va dire donc je
vais 50 g 5 ou des espoirs de topalov
qui jusqu'au bout maintenant il a
l'habitude de jouer ces parties du g5
éventuellement pour faire un petit peu
illusion lé droit il veut peut-être
menace est ainsi résolu sur le roi sur
le roi blanc
alors il y aurait quand même jouer on
peut se poser quand la question lui
jouer un coup comme cavalier trois
échecs
moi j'aimerais que le roi n'a pas de gaz
ici galfond et le seul coup pour le
droit d'en financer quasiment cg 2h en
ne passant pas très bon et la fougue et
cette foulée c'est pour faire une
découverte pour faire une petite
découvert mais qui menacera rien c'est à
dire qu'effectivement une fois que le
carbure à bouger il n'y aura pas de
vraie menace il faut pas avoir peur de
ce genre de petites combines on aimerait
comprendre simplement le pion et la
découverte
ne mène à rien il n'y a pas de pièces à
prendre car il est trop ou trop loin des
pièces ici pour faire des fourchettes
oui si on prend le pion est dans cette
position le cavalier peut venir en d2
leroy revient sur gerry chèque est sûre
cavalia 3le le roi peut l'envoyer en
effet à paris voilà il va s'en aller
puisque dans le fou ne peut plus venir
là donc à la tour on a pu repasser c'est
le surnom paix et qu'elles étaient de
plus ça va être tout simplement pour
dire que ça marchait pas donc topplers
g5 f4 de crâne pour avis prend son temps
maintenant et à son soutien quasiment
champion est mort ce point mort puisque
ce sont même s'il est protégé par le
cavalier tout simplement il pourra
rajouter une pièce à l'attaquant jouera
d'abord rondeau évidemment mais après on
attaquera le pion une dernière fois
d'avoir c'est un peu ce qui va se passer
je crois puisqu'après s4 caraïbes et
trois tours à trois attaques le cavally
et si lecavalier bouge
et bien c'est le pion qui tourne donc
toi pas le jour où ces quatre pour
protéger son cavalier et continuer à
protéger le pion mais après coup ces
sept
ça y est le pion aux morts donc il va
tomber et c'est chiant avec là pour ça
fait trop trop de matériel en plus après
g4 est fou prend 1,5
topalov justement abandonne la fin de
partie ne pose plus aucun problème
technique à un joueur de la classe de
kramnik superbe
on peut dire super pour le suspense du
match il superpose deux semaines du
match et puis aussi pour que ça fait
quand même plaisir de voir que craint
munich est pas et pas complètement à
l'agonie
oui voilà c'est ça qu'il arrive je suis
quand même à revenir malgré tout les
malheurs qui lui sont tombées depuis une
semaine mais oui pour la dernière
émission se poser la question de savoir
si s'il allait revenir ou pas et est une
sainte avoir dit qu'avec avec deux fois
les blancs tout était possible
et en plus avec l'expérience quand même
de champion cave la dynamique voilà il
l'a prouvé quand même dans cette partie
qu'un jeu un peu optimiste un jeu pas
forcément naturel doit être puni et de
la manière la plus simple
il a placé ses pièces très simplement et
il a réussi donc à a montré ce que
c'était le jeu classique à la chronique
donc le jeu plein de fantaisie topalov a
fonctionné quelques fois mais pas
aujourd'hui en tout cas pronostics pour
la fin du match et restent deux parties
plus les tie-breaks éventuelles est-ce
que ça va se terminer par deux nuls est
ce que l'un des joueurs va faire la
différence
ben
difficile à dire facile à dire c'est
vrai que quand même topalov a des nerfs
d'acier quand même quand même
l'impression sur cette partie qui l'a
quand même qu'il a craqué je pense pas
qu'ils aient vraiment craqué je pense
que total of est toujours très très
présent je crois que la force de topalov
c kom sa condition physique son énergie
qui est supérieure à celle de son
adversaire
ces faiblesses c'est que il a un jeu
quelquefois qui imprécis qui est un peu
trop un peu trop optimistes il tente
trop de choses et puis mes mais il a
tellement d'énergie quand même que c'est
comme ça qui fait que qu'il est numéro
un mondial actuellement le rang mondial
au classement elo veselin topalov valley
mercredi qu' toujours dans le coup pour
garder son titre classique
vainqueur du dernier champion du monde
classique de kasparov
on verra la suite d'un ses deux
dernières parties qui s'avère
passionnante qui aura forcément deux
parties puisque même si l'un des joueurs
gagner la prochaine
et bien il y aura il y aura une dernière
partie et éventuellement des tie break
en scène sans même dire que en grand à
grandir en spectateur de des grands prix
des grand prix de bordeaux et aix en
provence france où je serai favori pour
pour un tie break
ouais ouais ouais d'accord pour voir un
nouveau tie-break de parties rapides
en match ça pour être effectivement
c'est spectaculaire on verra ça en tout
cas voilà merci de nous suivre oubliez
pas d honnêteté vous pouvez vous abonner
aussi abonnez vous vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à nous écrire aussi bien
continuer merci de nous suivre et de
supporter cette émission et à bientôt